all right so now
let's juxtapose some sanity in florida
the governor fighting the insanity of
new york city which is the whole damn
thing but let's focus
on eric adams who is the new
mayor of new york city the new democrat
mayor and now remember
they had a true
socialist for a couple years in new york
city they had bill de blasio who was in
my opinion just a complete
communist socialist lunatic he destroyed
new york city
many many people have fled new york city
crime is out of control prices are out
of control we'll get to all that in just
a moment but what happened was when he
went out people said ah now we've got
eric adams and he'll be better about
this woke nonsense he'll be better about
policing
and i think he proved my theory that
there are no sane democrats left here is
new york city mayor eric adams that's
what this movement of don't say gay is
about uh this uh political
uh showmanship
of attempting to demonize a particular
group or community is unacceptable and
we are going to loudly show our support
and say to those who are living in
florida listen we want you here in new
york you know we want you right here in
new york city and it's more than just
saying that it's also standing up and
aligning ourselves
with the men and women of the lgbtq plus
community and stating that we are in
unisons with you and your right
to
have
self-identification
your right to be
live the lifestyle
and live uh the lives that you choose to
live without any form of harassment
yes everything that you just said there
eric adams was pure bunk you made up
what the bill is about you use the name
that is not actually the name and then
you pretended to say a bunch of things
that are completely nonsensical relative
to what's going on here in florida
literally today is tuesday four days ago
i gave a big talk in west palm beach at
the prageru gala i said hello and
introduced ron desantis brought him on
stage with dennis prager when he said
hello to me we shook hands he said dave
how are you i immediately turned to
david i said governor i want you to meet
my husband david he said hi to him we
took a big picture we were waiting on
the pictures it was with the official
photographer he said congratulations on
the kids this guy is not coming for
anyone's rights he's not coming for
anyone's marriage or anything else this
is about indoctrinating children so
everything eric adams said there is a
lie now what's interesting is the guy
that was standing behind eric adams over
his shoulder i'm not even sure who he is
he's someone in the administration but
he then uh basically took the microphone
and he said you know i know the mayor
won't say it but f ron desantis now that
video was posted on twitter and went
viral yesterday and then you're not
going to believe this guys because we
wanted to show it to you today uh it was
uh the account was suspended there was a
count by the name of mega jew okay and
all he did was post a public press
conference
on twitter the clip of a public press
conference and he got banned by
twitter so that's the state of free
speech and our ability to communicate
honestly but okay so here we go so now
the new york city mayor is absolutely
lying without question 100
lock sealed done lying about what's
going on here in florida and he's trying
to capitalize on it how is he doing it
well he tweeted this out with a big gay
picture
new york city's mayor's office breaking
new york city mayor announces a new
digital billboard campaign in five five
florida markets denouncing the hateful
don't say gay law and inviting
floridians to move to new york okay
first off let me be clear about
something you'd have to be a complete
effing [ __ ] to move to new york city
right now that's what you'd have to be i
think i'm being clear about uh my
feelings on that but we should compare
and contrast what's going on in florida
new york now first off people keep
saying this is the big one from the
media there are no schools that are
teaching any of this stuff they're not
indoctrinating these young kids in
elementary school uh with all of this
transgender stuff and that they can cut
off their gen genitals and be another
gender and all these things these things
aren't happening oh
image
yeah this is from libs of tick tock they
do a great job over there this is a
middle school in new york city it's
called the gateway school and there is a
young girl i assume it's a girl maybe
it's a boy a boy girl i don't know girl
boy uh who is giving some sort of
presentation related to all of the flags
of the lgbt community you've got the gay
flag and the trans flag and i don't know
what else is up there i can't even see
it from where i'm sitting but i you know
oh there's the asexual flag what's the
what's the flag with the uh with the
circle in it
the intersex flag what the hell give me
the camera what does this have to do
with education
what does being pansexual what does that
even mean you have sex with pans
demisexual
apache helicopter sexual what do any of
these things have to do with just two
plus two is four
a squared plus b squared is c squared
what is going on here this is all such
manipulated crapola